and here is the man of the hour our rich
eisen show gorilla glue toughest player
on planet earth player of the week from
the iowa hawkeyes the second ranked iowa
hawkeyes jack campbell linebacker how
are you jack
i'm good how are you doing sir i am
doing better for talking to you congrats
on everything that's going on with you
and your program
i appreciate it
so um what is going on with you and your
program second ranked and six and oh
what what has clicked for your team this
year jack i mean just coming into the
season uh all the guys we felt like we
had something special here and coach
francis has been preaching about uh just
focusing on us and i mean kind of some
things that he's like built into this
program
just being the best at uh fundamentals
and just having being men of high
character
and then just going out there and
playing with great effort and a great
have a great attitude walk into the
building every single day and
that's something all the guys on the
team are trying to exemplify right now
well this award is about again the
toughest player on planet earth but it's
about doing the tough jobs you were
already a big ten defensive player of
the week yet an 18 tackle game earlier
this season how do you view you doing
your tough job right there in the middle
of that hard-hitting defense jack what's
your approach
yeah i mean
my whole approach is just being able to
do anything i can to just make my team
successful and i'm just i just have such
a great opportunity to
to be playing in a at a big ten
university and just having the
opportunity to to work with coach phil
parker and coach seth wallace and coach
calvin bell and jane nieman
i kind of just owe everything to them
and just my teammates just doing their
job every single play so maybe i could
be free and maybe i could make a play
but
um
i just feel like uh
i just feel so proud to be an iowa
hawkeye and just the defense
just the tradition that phil parker's
created here it's just something special
so it's six five right you're six foot
five is that what you're listed or
you're listed at six three what are you
six five whatever oh yeah yeah why are
you six the linebacker six five that's
usually you're that's usually uh pretty
big for that spot yeah i'm not i'm not
sure i'm just kind of falling in love
with the position so
what do you love about it
i mean i just like the aspect of
you get a you get to kind of bring
everyone together and make sure
everyone's on the same page and that at
the same time you get a
you get to be in the middle you get to
be close to the action uh just have a
get getting to have a high motor and
just get a run around and play the great
effort
that's something that's kind of drawn me
to this position so it's okay to say you
want to hit people jack you can yeah
true true that is that is a bonus as
well you get
you get some good opportunities for that
well you certainly did with the penn
state quarterback sean clifford this
week walk me through that play that
changed the game
yeah i mean i was just uh
we had a blitz called and then
we saw something that we kind of wanted
to change up and i thought i'd have a
a pretty good shot on him
and my whole goal just going into it was
just to get a good clean shot on him
obviously i wanted to make him feel it a
little bit but at the same time you just
want to be smart
um you don't want to get a targeting or
erupting the passer um at the same time
you don't want to see anyone get injured
but i mean i was just trying to just
trying to do my job and
just honestly making a good aggressive
fast play and unfortunately ended up him
having to
leave the game but
i mean that's just
a testament to this program i mean we
work on just stuff fast all the time in
practice so all right so um is this your
first nil deal jack
uh
yeah okay
all right so with this rich eisen show
toughest player on planet earth award
presented by gorilla glue a thousand
bucks you can get some hard-earned cash
and then
glue the product
so
you know
i mean there's probably some around the
house we can get fixed up i'm going to
say like what what do you got look
let me help you what do you got jack
what do you need fixing around the house
i mean
there's a moped that has like a cracked
plastic fender that i've i've used
i've used some glue in the past but it's
not grilled glue and it didn't work and
then
also uh
our shades uh like little things snapped
off of it so we could probably use it
for that you can't have that um so your
stature can't have that cracked moped or
the the exactly the shape and i mean you
might get like maybe a cut in your skin
you could just glue your skin back
together
that's something that like my dad would
always do okay all right
i mean
good old iowa hands
good old iowa hands need fixing
what would it mean for you
to
go in the college football playoffs and
win a national championship for your
home state university with you right in
the middle of that defense what would
that mean for you
i mean yeah obviously it'd mean a lot i
mean it's every little little boy's
dream to grow up and win a national
championship at the college football
division one level
um and and specifically for me just
being from the state of iowa
a lot of people all over the country
kind of overlook you i'm at times so
just kind of having that extra chip on
my shoulder
i'm just trying to spread that to my
teammates and
just
see see how far we can get this thing
but at the same time just taking it a
week at a time i'm just focusing on the
things that have got us to this point
but all in all it would mean a lot to me
um just likewise a lot of other guys and
we just have had the great opportunity
to just
continue to have success so we just need
to keep doing what we've been doing so
well jack campbell we're not overlooking
you here with gorilla glue and the rich
eisen show congratulations on that uh
performance and everything that you've
done up to this point and good luck
moving forward unless you face
my alma mater and the big ten
championship game but you understand
that right i mean that's where we off to
part ways you know what i mean yeah
that's i can i can agree on that okay at
least you can respect that but right now
we'll just stick like gorilla glue like
this man congratulations on the nil
uh with gorilla glue and the rich eisen
show and uh best of luck moving forward
jack awesome thank you i appreciate it
sir
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here